best thing would you if a guy had all
the things you were looking for would
you accept him stepping out from time to
time I thought about this before
um yes no I'm not hang on
let me answer the question
um we have this notion that Menchie
right and so the thing is like if you've
already built and spent so many years
and you've invested so much of your life
of this person and they've stepped out
and if you genuinely believe that
Menchie if you leave to go to find love
a mountain then aren't you just gonna
end up repeating the circle again anyway
so are you not are you not better off
just staying in the position and working
it through but I don't condone it and I
do not respect it and you have to
understand that my behavior towards you
may change slightly as a result yeah I'd
like to always remain naive to the fact
that he's cheating I think if he brings
it to my doorstep I think it's more
about the disrespect more than anything
I think men cheat I think women women
take back men that don't tick all their
boxes so
to me is that not that I'm condoning
because I don't yeah and I don't accept
it but if I'm gonna take back somebody
who doesn't tickle my boxes then I'm
gonna take back somebody who does yeah
I think if we have like is it monogamous
where it's just like you're monogamous
to him but he
okay yeah every now and then no no no I
have to stay like that so that's why I'm
saying like if it's a monogamous
maybe if we've agreed to not do that and
he then did that yeah then we would I
don't know I feel like
at that stage you either have to decide
whether you want to work for it you
really love context sorry sorry
um if you agreed so you think you're
going to sit down with your man and
you're going to say well we're not going
to cheat and it's going to be a yes dear
I think it's like a continual
conversation
I think like especially nowadays like if
you're 20. if you're 20 years in yeah
you're gonna keep telling him I hope you
know we don't cheat here
like has your mind changed yeah we still
do exactly yeah that kind of
conversation are we opening up the
relationship no but it depends on your
your values
because a lot of women forget this and I
understand that you know words have
power and because you're reaffirming the
words that it might mean something but
you have to remember when it comes to
monogamy men conform to a woman's
reproductive strategy your reproductive
strategy is more keyed towards monogamy
whilst ours is scattergun so what you're
actually asking a man to do is go
against his own biological impulses to
cater to you so it's actually unfair to
ask that an expector when you're more
naturally catered to paved that way when
a man isn't this one when you're having
kids when you're having kids it might be
like cool we're monogamous right like
it's just us too but then afterwards
maybe once the kids have fled the home
you then might want to open up that
conversation and be like cool like shall
we open it
so would you be okay to have an open
relationship then I think I would
consider it yeah
I have I have a question you know she's
a feminist sir no it's not even about
being a feminist it's just like my
personal like what I'm okay with like so
yeah I think I would too I haven't been
in a 20-year relationship so I can't
tell you you know until I've got you
just open both ways okay I think if we'd
had kids been together for a long time
yeah I probably seriously I'll try it
yeah kids are no kids I will get my
immune system will shut down I'll die on
the sport bro I don't know I think like
if we've been together if I got like got
married if we had kids and like I'm like
50 whatever and we're like because thing
is like the whole marriage thing I'm
like well sometimes you might want to
just explore yeah and to be honest like
I don't um
baby I missed you it's like a ruined
yeah I don't know someone's younger and
more so I'll tell you what I try to I
think it comes to an arrogant place
because I think if she's with me and
she's the one that she's chosen then she
ain't finding better than me anyway
so it's almost like her going to another
Garden
no but what I mean I'm talking like
that's what I said after kids and
everything I'm saying if we've been
together
after kids and age and all of that she's
with she may be with you out of loyalty
not because your sex is good no no no
that's not what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying because you're saying
that she may not find better than yours
no no no no I'm saying better me as a
package like yeah but that's after she's
had kids and they're a lot older yeah
when basically her values her values
gone down
can you ask me would I do it I said
these are the conditions
you're gonna find her brother that's 20
years old yeah that's gonna slam her up
and he probably looked like you when he
was younger maybe and you're going to
see him I'm gonna think right nah [ __ ]
that I don't honestly I think at that
point like that happened I really I
don't think I would care because I'd be
like well if we want to both explore
let's explore can't find a 20 year old
so yeah
honestly I feel like if if my husband
let me let me explore that's the end of
the relationship for me I'm serious yeah
I think he's like he no longer feels
love for me he no longer cares about me
yeah that's how I feel yeah well I'm an
exceptionists you know not the actual
act I think it's the seat the deceit
yeah like you're going into the
relationship saying I'm going to be um
and then and then you go and do
something different like just be open
uninspire like yeah and come into
relationship I'm not promising again
girls will say this and it's all well
and good seeing it but in act acting it
out it doesn't work
that's the thing I've ever heard a girl
saying as soon as what you said I
remember being talking to a woman at
work and she's like she's been with her
boyfriend for 14 years and they're due
to get married and I just put into a
problem just poke calls I thought you
know he's probably cheating on you a few
times she goes listen I know but he's
never he's never brought that problem
home I think and I don't know about it
I'm happy so as long as I remain happy
and I don't know and I never see it I'm
okay with what he does but as a mature
woman's mind I think that most women
don't go in there thinking oh yeah this
guy is just for me I don't think isn't
that what you just said that you have to
have that conversation yeah I don't
think you do have to have that
conversation like so why is having the
conversation a bad thing or why does it
have to be like it's not realistic
because most people don't want honesty
like let's just come on let's just be
yeah
so I 100 I have a question
um so you you threw your your single
moms right do you feel like it's fair to
accept accept monogamy
um or to expect monogamy from someone
when you've given someone else a child
so they're not getting the youth and
like the Purity that they want I don't
remember I don't agree with your belief
so okay I'm gonna say no I would say
don't pick me in the first place yeah
yeah I didn't realize you were kids too
yeah
is it do you me yeah okay
um yeah no
okay I think it depends on the guy
doesn't it like because if he's like
actually too fair if you said no then
fine but I think the higher value a man
is the more likely a woman is going to
accept that but if he's like just so
average if you're going to accept that
you're gonna accept that anyway not
because you've got kids not because
that's what that's why I say no I think
if a woman's gonna accept that she's
going to accept that but I think most
women do accept it
I'm saying like how do most
relationships start nowadays
situationships as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible